if you look at abraham lincoln  he had what i'd call tragic optimism you  read his speeches he was so optimistic  for the future  we're gonna get this done  we're gonna free slaves like we're gonna  change the country we're gonna get  through this  but in the day-to-day  in the war despair despair yeah and i'm  not saying you need to take it to that  extreme  but that's how i kind of see this  embracing reality is  you need to have hope for the future you  need to say i'm going to stretch  i'm capable of more etc  but in the here and now you got to have  it kind of overlap where it's like what  am i facing what do i have to do what do  i need to get through this period mm-hmm